he was like hey I have an idea for a
show and what was that it's your arm I'm
sorry you were so anyway this is where
we would live this show is magnificent I
happy cried i sad cried all the cries
throughout the shows this came from epic
magazine these profiles that they did
can you talk a little bit about at what
point you were like this is a show while
so as you said epic magazine had been
collecting these stories and at some
point I think was it I don't know who
they contacted Lee or legal Josh Behrman
of epic magazine and leave I think to
the brows and they just were kind of
discussing it and Lee Lisa genius and is
always kind of looking for the newest
kind of opportunity he's very very smart
at recognizing things that could work
don't ever show him this I don't want
him to know I'm commenting and then he
and Josh are talking about it and then
Lee came to us to see if we have an idea
for a show anyway and then we came to us
yeah we got dinner with them and he was
like what do you think of an anthology
show based on true stories of amazing
it's so lovely to hear an idea that
you're like why doesn't this exist
already obviously this should happen and
it's wonderful when you're being asked
to be involved in something that already
feels like something that should exist
yeah quicks I know
are you still adjusting to the ovals
it's like you see him every day but the
internet was like what yeah and so much
is the thing the internet thought it
happened overnight whereas people I know
I've been talking about it it's
incessantly for a year yeah that's true
and the way you look almost makes up for
how much you talk about it I'm trying to
do it last night but yeah I got obsessed
with it yeah because it just takes so
much work then it's something you
relieve yeah it's been a great thing for
you but also he's much warmer like
physically warmer I think he's like do
you just heard like a little heat
factory now in a way that you weren't
before it's kind of amazing Camille
what's been your favorite reaction so
far because mine has to be that you were
featured as the muscular men on
on the rocks eggs don't think about it
that was very exciting he was like he
called me brother and he said I know how
hard it is to I was like oh that one
felt great
wouldn't you say it'd probably be like
it could be the girl I went to middle
school with that I hadn't talked to
since middle school or the guy hooked up
was in college who both reached out to
me oh those meant very little to me
compared to Dwayne the rock Johnson
probably I don't really care about the
guy you're better than the guy you
hooked up with in college someone gave
your father socks with your body on them
yeah that was wow there's merch today
yeah yeah Wow
I didn't know there was Kumail Bob merch
now and then was it was privately made I
think well jump on this make some extra
extra cash I know okay come back to the
show
I one of my favorite things at the end
of the episodes are the real life
pictures how involved were these real
life subjects and do you a favor ended
yeah depended on what the subjects
wanted all of them kind of signed all of
them knew that we were going to take
their stories and make in something we
were in so we're gonna fictionalize
their stories and some of them kind of a
couple of them visited set a couple of
them had a lot more in-depth talks with
epic magazine to kind of when we were
kind of shaping the episodes and then
some of them are like yeah just take it
do whatever you need with it I'm done so
it was sort of dictated by them how
involved they were yeah
now you guys there are more episodes in
the works I believe yeah we've just
started talking about what stories to
the second it is simple there's an
amazing room that we've assembled for
the second season too so I'm excited
awesome I love I mean I love the show so
much I want to ask really quick about
one of the episodes that I think made me
cry the most was the Sun and to find out
that was banned at 11 countries was
pretty heartbreaking what was your guys
you know reaction to that and uh it is
heartbreaking because a lot of those
countries are where I think people would
connect to it the most it was not
something we were aware of until we
found out about it on Twitter
yeah aye-aye-aye
there's a way around it we have been
talking to Apple trying to figure out a
way to put the episode out in some
regards whether or not that's I don't
know but we're just trying to work out a
way to do it and I would say you know
I'm I'm very against illegal downloading
of stuff however however for this one
episode I'm like apples backer like get
it for free give it to everybody for
free I think that'd be great I think
that banning things never the goal is to
erase it and it only ever draws
attention to it and we have no problem
with more attention being drawn to that
episode because we love that upset yeah
there's I mean you know Steven and Amuro
and Haase and Adam really poured
themselves into that episode and they
were so passionate about it and you can
really you can really feel that passion
in the episode so I really hope that
we're working on it
yeah when we were very devastated yeah
well it's a great show you guys should
be so proud
[Music]